il y eut de gaulle adenauer pompidou
brandt mais le premier vrai couple
franco allemand celui qui a construit
l'union européenne c'est lui valéry
giscard d'estaing helmut schmidt c'était
dans les années 70 alors à l'arrêt
vge schmitt de chef d'état deux amis une
ligne politique différente mais il cause
commune
1974 à peine élu les deux dirigeants
veulent réveiller une europe endormi
c'est la naissance du conseil européen
le sommet européen est mort vive le
conseil européen les dirigeants
européens s'y réunissent et définissent
la politique générale de lieux autre
initiative de vge schmitt les élections
européennes au suffrage universel direct
pour le parlement c'est une première et
en france c'est acté dès juin 1977 avec
la signature d'un texte de loi la
session parlementaire qui s'achève
aujourd'hui a donc permis l'adoption du
projet de loi sur l'élection au suffrage
universel des représentants de la france
à l'assemblée parlementaire européen et
les actions continuent milieu des années
70 toujours crise économique les
monnaies européennes varie sans cesse
valéry giscard d'estaing et helmut
schmidt veulent déstabiliser il crée le
système monétaire européen l'annoncé
faite lors du sommet de copenhague en
avril 1978 nous avons mis l'accent sur
la nécessité de rétablir un système
stable de taux de change dans la
communauté et c'est maintenant aux
institutions de la communauté de faire
des propositions à cet égard presqu'un
an plus tard le 13 mars 1979 le système
monétaire européen entre en vigueur ce
sont les prémices de l'euro c'est une
date importante pour l'europe parce que
avions des taux de change entre nous qui
fluctuaient sans arrêt et qui
introduisait un élément d'incertitude
dans tout dans l'investissement dans les
échanges le couple franco-allemand a
continué d'oeuvrer main dans la main
pour l'union européenne jusqu'au 21 mai
1981 date de départ de valéry giscard
d'estaing de l'elysée
[Musique]